[Musique]
luthérienne
salut les terriens alors les terriens de
ce soir sont marie arlette carlotti
marianne
alors marié relate vous êtes ministre
délégué chargé des handicapés il ya un
truc que je comprends pas dans le
gouvernement héros le ministre chargé de
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale fraude
est lui même et la ministre chargée des
handicapés n'est pas
bien franchement c'est très inquiétant
autres terrienne avec nous ce soir enora
malagré
alors on aura vous avez beaucoup de
succès dans touche pas à mon poste sur
d8 ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes plus la blonde à côtés de cyril
hanouna mais que cyril hanouna et le
pakistanais a coûté demeurer à manhattan
autres terriens avec nous ce soir patry
guen
[Applaudissements]
après qu'est ce qui s'est passé n'a pas
changé un que c'était devenu tu t'es
marié tas de gamins de
5 ambitionner d'être heureux dans la vie
ta réussite on paye finalement
oui oui vraiment et autres querrien
edouard martin mesdames messieurs
bonsoir vous êtes le leader cfdt de
l'usiné arcelormittal de florange vous
publiez un livre vous êtes une star des
plateaux télé vous allez vous lancer
dans la politique
alors qu'est ce qu'on dit on dit merci
lakshmi mittal
à vous croyez tu poses kobe 10 ans mercy
héros
en p3 après deux avis et gaspard proust
nous accueillerons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir aurélien brûlé
y vit parmi les singes gibbons de bornéo
et puis se bat pour leur survie voilà
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
et le groupe et gréements le portier
mais
alors patrick rebond soir donc j'avais
fait un triomphe au théâtre et au cinéma
avec le prénom trois millions et demi
d'entrées quand on voit ce que font les
films aujourd'hui c'est absolument
colossal vous avez été nommé pour le
césar du meilleur acteur votre album
lequel de nous cartonne je n'avais pas
peur d'une nouvelle bruel magna patrick
je l'attends avec impatience ouais alors
il ya vingt ans vous ne pouviez pas
manger une pizza aux champs elysées
parce que ça crée des émeutes est
aujourd'hui non plus parce que votre
nutritionniste vous l'interdît toute
sa marque et mis une veste mais c'est
pas pour cacher les formes se montrer
vente non
non mais tout va bien pour patrick bruel
à batman album lequel de nous marchent
très fort on commence par regarder à
quoi ça ressemble
des yeux monsieur s'ouvrir je me ferai
un chemin au milieu des angie elle me
prendre
on se regarde
[Musique]
loin devant
auj
c'est ce top 3 j'étais là mais rien de
celle qui maintenant j'étais là bas
juste un sourire un tee shirt marqué
comment
je
store
je la cherche dans toutes les personnes
juste un peu
de détail chacun
voilà pas très bref six secondes exprès
de lequel de nous son dernier album hors
batterie puis seule question c'est qu'il
ya fille caroline ford n ont pas mal
jeune actrice anglaise qui est en train
de vraiment de percées même les états
unis alors lequel de nous c'est un album
très attendu on retrouve un peu le côté
alors regarde je trouve ya une espèce
d'intensité qui est qui est comparable
alors regarde c'était extraordinaire
c'est à dire que ça a été le point de
départ de la bruel manière des années 90
c'était sorti le 9 novembre 1989
le jour où le mur de berlin tombait
alors maintenant on pouvait le dire est
ce que c'est une coïncidence
c'était failli coïncidence mais l'album
et venait de sortir et j'ai écrit une
chanson
deux semaines plus tard qui s'appelle
combien de muret j'ai attendu quatre ans
on avait deux sur un album elle avait
été écrite en effet dès la chute du mur
ou d'arn réside actuellement en tournée
dans toute la france donc du 29 mai au
31 mai au zénith de paris mais c'est
complet c'est complet complet l'accord
est complet qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
pour y aller aller à bercy le 22 juin
[Applaudissements]
non sérieusement on sait qu'avant même
la sortie des albums les gens
réservaient déjà oui il ya une fidélité
qui s'est installé depuis longtemps elle
plus que mam a mené à bout la tenue à
bout de bras comme ça a été même un peu
plus difficile
ça c'est c'est une manne en salle et ses
revenus on pense
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment patrick entre le disque
les concerts le théâtre le cinéma le
poker vous gagner beaucoup d'argent et
vous avez déclaré quoi qu'il arrive je
resterai en france vous dire vous avez
encore les moyens d'être français vous
j'ai les moyens déjà les moyens des
transepts suivi à partir du moment où
les choses deviennent à peu près normale
1 par rapport à des déclarations qui
avaient été faites il ya un an et c'est
vrai on parle plus des 75 % margaret
alors on en parle un peu autrement bon
c'est quand même normal qu'on participe
à l'effort collectif en plein champ sur
moi tout ce que j'avais dit à l'époque
c'était simple je trouvais cette mesure
contre productive parce qu'elle était
elle était parce que quand on parlait de
75 ça arrivait à 93 95 96 97 pour
certains voient là c'était là où ça
devenait un peu un peu con quoi alors si
les gains de poker deviennent imposables
allait faire comment
ça va pas devenir imposable et en plus
je joue pas beaucoup là vous êtes
toujours actionnaire du site de poker
winamax ce jour ce qui est bien avec le
poker c'est que je crois que l'on peut
gagner beaucoup d'argent avec winamax il
vaut mieux être actionnaires que joueur
ce n'est pas l'intérêt des actionnaires
dont ce parti de voir des gens se ruiner
sur des sites ce qu'il faut c'est que
beaucoup de gens jouent entre eux en
s'amusant en passant du temps on ne
profite pas de la perte de quelqu'un on
profite du fait que les gens jouent
entre eux ce qui est agréable c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on peut jouer en ligne
perdre en ligne être ruinée en ligne est
ce qu'on peut se suicider en ligne
c'est le sujet d'une des chansons de mon
album qui s'appelle mots d'enfant et
ouais que j'ai écrit à la suite de 400
suicides qui était arrivé sur internet
après que des jeunes gens étaient
harcelés par d'autres de manière
tellement violente voilà cette chanson
ou la fouine m'a rejoint pour un brin du
haut des airs vous êtes toujours fans de
foot oui c'est pas trop facile d'être
supporter du psg en ce moment c'est
quand même plus difficile et plus ingrat
à l'époque on avait peur que le psg
descendent en ligue 2 oui à l'époque oui
c'était plus dur aujourd'hui c'est c'est
vrai que c'est une équipe très de très
haut niveau mais on attend que on attend
que d'autres clubs peut-être essaie de
se mettre à niveau et il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas de grand championnat sans un
grand poème donc mais s'attend à ce que
j allais joueurs mais l'om à la ferveur
oh oui c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
projet oui mais franchement
cavité pas loin de l'isle sur sorgue
j'aime bien l'om quelle horreur on me
fait l'accent n'est pas bon
alors l'avantagé que les qatari
m'annoncer que j'ai pu aussi à côté de
monaco macias n'a côtés de victoria
beckham
on nous a dit la france espagne au stade
de france avec votre nouvelle fiancée
attendait il a le droit d'avoir des
fiancés qu'on aime enfin bon temps mais
patrick j'ai toujours été plus fidèle à
votre public à vos femmes c'est vrai
pour être
c'est vrai là ça faisait des fidélités
successives la fidélité dure le temps de
l'étonnement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeu bon j'en suis plus en plus
convaincus et ouais je n'ai jamais été
aussi étonné
enora malagré re bonsoir
on est chroniqueuse dans l'émission
touche pas à mon poste de cyril hanouna
sur des 8es vous êtes ici ce soir parce
que vous avez déclaré au magazine tv
grandes chaînes thierry ardisson est mon
idole depuis toujours il est le plus
grand interviewer du siècle ouais
serrières du son est votre idole
est vraiment non mais tu iras le sens
quand même le mec qui a osé demander art
car si sucer c'est tromper c'est vrai
que en fait entre une carrière il des
conneries comme ça mais vous êtes mon
idole voilà merci d'être là papa maman
chez ardisson
alors vous êtes ici ce soir également
parce que vous avez reçu le buzz a world
de la meilleure animatrice tnt les
animatrices tlt sans avoir été miss
france ou perdante de la star ac c'est
quand même assez extraordinaire
sans avoir couché dit dans ce que je
savais que hanouna ah non non non c'est
comme si la presse vous pécho voix
annonce est un bon nom ni jamais c'est
vraiment mon frère on est d'accord ça
fait aussi partie de mes idoles
d'ailleurs j'aimerais être quand je
serai grand j'aimerais être moitié vous
at il ajouté surtout mal qu'on vous
souhaite en tous les cas oui mais
absolument et avec est clair comment ça
va mais je vous en position
et vous et moi tu meurs ça va très très
bien je très amoureux ça se voit
j'avais aussi été présentatrice télé la
plus sexy par les lecteurs du magazine
têtu et têtu le magazine des hommes qui
aiment les hommes ouais c'est au côté
mec
avant je m'appelais paul a fait pour ça
ils s'en souviennent alors le journal le
parisien parle de vous comme la tornade
blonde qui décoiffe j'imagine que c'est
un compliment pour eux
c'est ça nous fait plaisir tout ça ben
oui ça fait plaisir sur ma maman mon
papa mais bien sûr que ça fait plaisir
et je me prends aussi énormément de scud
1 dans la tête j'ai à là où on parle de
la petite partie en plus en ce moment
marc yevou les gens je sais pas pourquoi
même bien mais je divise beaucoup je
fais assez peu l'unanimité où on aime ou
on déteste justement j'ai discuté avec
jean luc lahaye alors jean luc lahaye
voulez vous donner une fessée et troquer
vos fesses passionnant il a déclaré que
j'ai tjrs et une gogo danseuse payer aux
bouchons j'ai quand même pas très sympa
et vous n'avez qu'à si vous avez dit je
ne suis rien alors que lui c'est un
grand artiste du 14e siècle
on l'a regardé une vidéo maintenant qui
va faire très plaisir jean luc lahaye
aux non pas six
[Musique]
à
hu
alors c'est quoi cette histoire
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes jeune vous aviez besoin de
vent mais vous êtes toujours de produits
de lab sont ils pas j'avais seize vous
empêchez plus puis on est avec des poses
c'était une petite parodie ou avec des
copains et que maintenant on me ressort
mais c'est bien ça oui tout à votre
honneur les cas je voudrais faire
voilà c'était la paire de skis on se
rend trois prédateurs ont discuté
qualité leur salut à tous
[Musique]
re bonsoir les terrienne revanche sur
les terrains nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de marie arrus
dès lors à malagré
de patrick bruel
et des toits martin
alarie wehrmacht un rebond soir bonsoir
dans la france entière vous connais
comme le leader syndicaliste cfdt de
l'usiné arcelormittal de florange mais
vous êtes ici ce soir car vous publiez
un livre intitulé ne lâchons rien aux
éditions du cherche midi un livre vous
rendez compte edwards se fout merci
lakshmi mittal encore vous rassure c'est
pas lui qui m'a appris à écrire
alors j'ai lu votre livre alors autant
vous le dire tout de suite ça m'a pas du
tout donner envie de venir sidérurgiste
c'est dur franchement je suis d'horloge
ça me donne pour but d' état du moteur
c'est un livre assez touchant vous
raconter comment vous avez fui la
dictature franquiste pour vous retrouver
sous une autre dictature la dictature
des marchés alors ça commence en espagne
un jour votre grand père veut faire
paître ses vaches sur une immense
propriété en friche mais le terrain
appartient à l'église et on le menace de
prison bah oui ce qu'elle pouvoir
c'était les généraux et l'église comme
et ça ça n'a pas changé
l'église est toujours du côté du
puissant clan alors un autre jour votre
père revient du travail et en marchant
comme ça il lâche 1 p ça arrive tu
arrives et la guardia civil l'art est le
frappe il a balancé une boutade il était
avec son frère la dc pour celui qui
vient derrière il n'avait pas remarqué
que c'était la guardia civil est
d'accord ces prix il s'est pris une
raclée comme manque de bol
mais à l'époque pour un rien ils étaient
tout puissants ils avaient tous les
droits il fallait surtout pour l'espagne
parce que vous vous reprenez une raclée
alors donc vous partez en france parce
que votre père a trouvé un travail à
gandrange et vous raconter le voyage
vers la france alors 8 dans une 404 quoi
berline oui c'était trois jours de
voyage s'étaient alors à l'époque c'est
je crois la première fois je préfère
d'une voiture quand même alors c'était
magique mais au bout de trois jours je
peux vous assuré c'était l'enfer qu'elle
contrôle réguler de manière régulière le
cul de celle à la route des manouches
quoi et alors en arrivant vous êtes
logée dans une hlm et là vous voyez les
premiers vrais wc de votre vie quoi
c'est vrai la première salle de bains
avec douche baignoire toilettes fabre fc
des choses que nous n'avions pas mais
c'était grand luxe oui pour les jours
zèle à l'école avec des sandalettes quoi
comme un petit espagnol avec une chemise
boutonnée jusqu ici tout le monde se
fout de notre gueule ça a été ma
première humiliation je voyais les rires
moqueurs
et franchement je si j'avais pu les
bouffées c'est sûr mais bon voilà
ensuite vous racontez votre embauche
dans la sidérurgie en fait les trois
huit oui pour un smic à 3000 francs à
l'époque et finalement ça vous plaît
comme le spectacle de l'acier en fusion
si les choses dont vous parlez souvent
dans votre bouquin ça vous a ému c'est
le coup de foudre brin je vois de ces
gros blocs d'acier rougeoyant voilà ça
vous prend aux tripes ça s'explique pas
et ça fait 32 ans que ça dure et puis
ensuite l'arrivée évidemment de lakshmi
mittal sa volonté de fermer gandrange et
là vous êtes reçus à l'elysée par
nicolas sarkozy
voulu expliquer la situation et ils vous
répondent vous avez goûté mes chocolats
ce n'est pas qu'ils me répondent c'est
qu'il m'interrompt dans l'explication
parce qu'envoyer bien qu'il n'avait que
faire des explications qu'on lui donne
et il regardait plafond sans bref on
l'emmerdé je l'emmerdé c'est terrible
puis après de toute façon j'ai pas j'ai
pas réussi à expliquer le dossier juin
du matériau plan dix ans mais finalement
ici je vais avoir droit qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
aucun intérêt à ce que vous gagnez et là
ils boudent comme un gosse il se tourne
il dit bombes si le pack je viens je
viens pas voilà
mais il est venu mais parce qu'à un
moment donné hui voulait venir donc il
est président il est venu pendant son
voyage de noces en plus il s'est marié
je crois c'était un samedi et le lundi
suivant il était venu à gandrange et le
4 février 2008 je m'en souviendrai
toujours un temps de merde il pleuvait
les pieds dans la gadoue et qui à la fin
de son discours opus il se fout de notre
gueule il dit gandrange comme voyage de
noces ya pas mieux
voilà ils se foutent de notre gueule en
plus alors ensuite mittal fermera à
gandrange et puis hollande pendant la
campagne il vous dit écoutez si je suis
élu toute façon il n'y a pas de problème
monsieur martin il y aura une loi qui
interdira de fermer les usines rentable
cette fois l'entente toujours oui vous
avez vous fait des merguez et collants
d'un gel passe pas elles restent coincés
là jamais malbouffe et des merguez
samedi 14 de bouffées de fumée relève
aussi des cailloux et c'est pour ça que
françois hollande doit revenir à
florence il nous doit ça en attendant
les hauts fourneaux sont fermées depuis
jeudi dans les hauts fourneaux sont
morts définitivement mort je sais pas si
certains dorment bien depuis je pense
qu'il ya des consciences qui doivent
vous avez été trahi par tout le monde
finalement non je dirais pas ça
franchement si ravaux arlement bourde a
mouillé la chemise il a fait le taf il a
fait le boulot avec son équipe il aurait
il cherché un repreneur qu'ils ont
trouvé le dossier industriel était
ficelé le montage financier était bouclé
et donc cette victoire on la touche et
c'est un peu comme le pg l'autre jour il
est à deux doigts de ce qualificatif
patatras il ya messi qui rentrent en jeu
ici c'est la série heroes halper a eu
peur parce que le mot nationalisation
est devenu un gros mot une insulte en
france depuis alors que dans notre
esprit il ne s'agissait pas de
nationaliser advitam eternam de florent
et faire ce qu'a fait obama avec lantus
et apidra cannes mittal veut fermer un
fleuron de l'industrie française
aujourd'hui le seul qui légitiment
apprendra bien privé à quelqu'un dans
l'intérêt général l'intérêt du pays
c'est l'état et là il a eu peur et en
même temps il s'est servi de ça pour
régler le compte de montebourg et ça je
trouve ça horrible quoi j'attends
j'attends pas ça d'un élu de la
république et encore moins de la premier
ministre
mais ceci dit il n'y a pas eu de casse
sociale tout cas ça sert et ça ça
s'appelle de la com vous êtes monsieur
ayrault entre la retombée de la
communication de monsieur sarkozy à
gandrange les 575 s'avérer de l'endroit
n'ont pas été licenciés c'est vrai et
les 400 sous traitants on en fait quoi
et sous traitants ce sont les plus
fragiles les plus faibles or rien n'a
été prévu pour eux ils sont d'ores et
déjà licencié donc vous ne pouvez pas
dire qu'à pas de casse sociale je viens
vraiment edwards il ya mis chômeur
nouveau en france cinq jours si si on
compare ça alors là dans ce cas là n'a
plus qu'à se taire ont remballé pillon
on demande même pardon de demander des
choses je dis simplement à un moment
donné justement où on a mille chômeurs
par jour lorsqu'il ya un repreneur qui
vient qui et qui est prêt à mettre sa
100 millions d'euros et à un
professionnel ou maintenir l'ensemble
des emplois et y compris à créer de
l'emploi je pense qu'en tant crise ne va
pas faire la fine bouche quoi parce que
les mêmes qui aujourd'hui veulent nous
[ __ ] chômage demain ce seront les
mêmes qui nous reprocheront des
désastres east et et de profiter du
système social or nous on veut profiter
de revient on veut être des hommes
dignes qui gagne en notre salaire
dignement en travaillant et pas en
bénéficiant de dictionnaires
[Applaudissements]
évidemment maintenant quand on vous
voilà en comprendrez que vous vous
lanciez dans une carrière politique
alors attendez il faut arrêter avec les
fantasmes lorsque j'ai émis l'idée que
nous étions réflexion pour voir si on
demain n'allait pas rentrer aux
politiques les copains et moi c'est
parce que au bout de vingt mois du
combat on aura tout fait en terme
d'action syndicale des piquets de grèves
des blocages en est même venu à pied
jusqu'à paris vous n'avez reçu à ce
moment-là sarkozy vous a reçus à la
imagen exactement et je me suis rendu
compte en fréquentant les élus des uns
des autres que finalement tout ça ça les
émeut pas ça les effraye absolument pas
là où je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
commencent à flipper c'est lorsque des
gens comme nous disons peut-être que
nous on veut être candidat parce que
ceux qui ont fait de la politique un
métier tout d'un coup ils ont peur ils
se disent ils sont peut-être pas élu
mais peut me faire perdre mon siège est
ce que vous auriez les capacités d'être
un homme politique monte pour voir oui
j'aurais capacité d'être un homme
politique
alors marie-arlette bonsoir ça met plus
listre délégué aux personnes handicapées
et à la lutte contre l'exclusion et vous
publié au cherche midi marseille m'a
capitale alors vous êtes en charge des
handicapés et des sdf
mais comment ça se vous êtes arrivé la
dernière le géant de la distribution des
bénéfices
non pas du tout mais je suis ravi de
prendre en charge des gens qui en ont
besoin travaillant sur un plan autisme
j'ai travaillé sur un une conférence de
lutte contre la pauvreté la précarité on
augmente le rsa on augmente la cmu c non
je fais les choses concrètes positive en
plus je le prends à coeur et vous en
êtes où d embauche des travailleurs
handicapés dans le service public ce
qu'on est loin des 6 % absolument
absolument c'est un engagement très
important que nous avons pris et ça
c'est mon objectif deuxième semestre
2013 je vais mettre le paquet sur cette
gestuelle est ce que finalement les
entreprises préfèrent pas payer des
amendes qu'embaucher les handicapés
alors déjà on a dit que si ça marchait
pas on augmenterait les amendes et dans
les entreprises les salariés sont prêts
à aider l'autre à ouvrir le poste de
travail à les accompagner vraiment pour
moi c'est l'objectif de ma demain farrar
accès les accès au transport etc il n'ya
pas d'avion on est quand même un des
pays où il ya le moins de possibilité de
circuler pour les handicaps excusez moi
mais vous avez l'air très intéressant et
puis handicapé moment pas vous mais vous
avez quelqu'un de proche qui était
handicapée non mais ça me donne cette
question de société c'est vrai on ne
sait très bien effectivement ça me
touche alors on vous connaît pas bien
non donc voilà regarde et arlette
carlotti en même temps qu'elle est pas
bien le premier ministre non plus
alors marié relate vous allaitez porte
parole de jean noël guérini mis en
examen pour détournement de fonds
publics aujourd'hui vous préférez rien
lui portait peut-être des oranges aux
baumettes non il est pas encore
baumettes et puis ceci dit moi j'aime
beaucoup les oranges les mangerait
moi-même d'abord mais oui j'étais porte
parole mais après je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait plus que je porte
cette parole là alors vous avez été
lundi matin la première à publier votre
patrimoine vous croyez vraiment que pour
gérer une ville comme marseille on peut
faire confiance à quelqu'un qui a aussi
peu d'argent sur son compte et en place
franchement c'est une misère
encore ce mon compte courant ils
évoluent très vite ouais il ya en fait
deux mois j'ai encore moi mais
finalement moi j'en ai comme j'ai dit
que j'en avais comme les couches
moyennes ce qui n'est pas vrai elle
qu'il faut faire attention mais oui on
peut me faire confiance j'ai joué la
transparence ah ça c'est sûr vous n'avez
pas de compte en suisse - regardez moi
comme cahuzac avec monsieur j'ai pas
content suis une relation tellement
serait avec l'argent des biens ainsi que
ce que tu veux oui mais ben il est en
même temps quand on est ministre du
budget en temps de crise faut savoir
mentir parce que il faut savoir sur tout
c'est quand tu avais arrêté aujourd'hui
suicide il faut savoir surtout ne pas
accepter ce poste un ton c'est qu'on a
un compte en suisse sur la réduction du
déficit public à 3 % aimanté aussi je
pense pas assez du mc que ces contrôles
en aujourd'hui la ilaha illa moins
d'opinions positives que francis heaulme
c'est quand même et non pour maison mais
ça marche pas du tout qu'est-ce vous à
des fleurs à continuer à vous continuez
continuez à positiver vous voyez bien
qu'on est en train d'avancer sur des
propositions très claires pour jouer la
transparence de tous les côtés pour
rétablir la confiance avec les français
on va en parler de justement avec
l'édito de blacko et c'est yves thréard
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro que nous retrouverons sur ce
plateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
est ce que c'est vraiment une bonne idée
d'obliger les ministres à rendre public
leur patrimoine en tout cas c'est
marrant de savoir que montebourg s'est
offert un fauteuil à 4000 euros que du
cloud roulant 4l ou qu'eva joly s'est
payé des kayaks de qu'on fait en carbone
prenantes le bon peuple lorgnent les
puissances un trou de la serrure ça lui
évite de s'intéresser aux vrais
scandales
on soupçonne ainsi qu à usak d'avoir mis
ses relations au ministère de la santé
au service de grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques qui le paient cher pour
ça nous avons une proposition nouveau
faire
de mélange de dollars mais ce n'est pas
le seul politique à être copain avec les
milliardaires du médicament avant d'être
un président de la république
irréprochable
sarkozy y était l'avocat d'affaires des
laboratoires servier il a même décoré
servier du plus haut grade dans la
légion d'honneur le conflit d'intérêts
c'est un fléau de la vie publique
exemple eric woerth un ministre du
budget censée lutter contre la fraude
fiscale or sa femme gérait la fortune de
liliane bettencourt qui justement
planquer du fric en suisse
après un tel scandale sarkozy a donc
décidé de moraliser la vie publique je
demanderai une commission de réfléchir
pour éviter dans l'avenir toute forme
qui pourrait intervenir de conflit
d'intérêts il a commandé un rapport qui
est devenu un projet de loi adopté en
conseil des ministres seul petit
problème le texte n'a jamais été
présenté à l'assemblée la loi n'a donc
jamais été voté
puisque la ferveur tu ne faisais plus la
une des journaux à quoi bon impose
excuses de contrôle à l'ensemble de la
classe politique
le besoin de moraliser se fait surtout
sentir lorsqu'un scandale éclate
quand bernard arnault voulait devenir
belge est bien cambadélis a réclamé la
création d'une commission d' enquête sur
l'évasion fiscale bonne idée sauf que
cette commission existait déjà
quelques mois plus tôt elle avait rendu
un rapport accablant et estime que
l'évasion fiscale fait perdre chaque
année 50 milliards à l'état une somme
équivalente aux coups de jets de
l'éducation nationale rien de ça alors
cette fois c'est promis le gouvernement
a décidé de s'attaquer aux paradis
fiscaux pour de vrai les paradis fiscaux
doivent être éradiquées pourquoi pas on
veut bien les croire en attendant
on est quand même impatient de connaître
le montant de la fortune de fabius
s'est elle évite aux deux plateaux mise
en image de julien grappes il ferait un
bon soir en force est directeur adjoint
de la rédaction du figaro bienvenue
parmi nous merci alors après le choc de
compétitivité après le choc de
simplification suite à la sphère cahuzac
voici le choc de moralisation en tout
cas sa paire de créer un choc de
popularité ni un choc de crédibilité
dans l'opinion hollande veut régler le
problème en une semaine c'est à se
demander pourquoi il l'a pas fait plus
tôt si c'était si simple que ça alors on
va commencer avec le patrimoine d'abord
donc marie-arlette je répète vous était
la première lundi à dévoiler votre
patrimoine alors tout le monde est
d'accord effectivement sur un contrôle
là où il ya débat c est ce qu il faut
que ce soit public ou pas les gens
disent la transparence oui le voyeurisme
non alors vous vous en pensez quoi marc
fière d'être alors ses joyaux rist non
mais c'est pas la solution uniquement ce
qui est intéressant pour un élu c'est de
savoir ce qu'il a au départ
quand il à son mandat et qu'est ce qu'il
a à l'arrivée et ce qui est intéressant
c'est ce qui est en train de proposer
justement françois hollande pas une
commission une de plus il propose la
mise en place d'une haute autorité qui
va vérifier nos patrimoines qui aura la
possibilité d'investigation de nous
demander et puis on refera la même chose
à la fin pour voir parce que dans la
réalité ou s'enrichit pas quand on fait
de la politique si on la fait
normalement donc et il n'est pas
question de dire et de stigmatiser ceux
qui sont un peu plus d'argent ceux qui
en ont moins
c'est à dire arriver parce que regardez
regardez fillon par exemple il est venu
à la télé il dit regardez j'ai une
pauvre maison j'ai acheté quatre cent
quarante mille euros maintenant elle
veut aussi s'en sont pris l'eau sauf
quand on voit la photo de la maison que
tu ne maison m en fait pas non plus
énorme mais pour tout le monde il habite
dans un château mais donc les gens
chaque fois qu'il va ouvrir sa bouche
les gens vont lui parler de son château
et je ne vois pas comment finir le mois
et on voit que ce mec là effectivement
nous mais à la tête un château enfin
vous imaginez bien que si ça alors ça se
produit dans beaucoup de pays européens
dans beaucoup de pays modernes ils n'ont
pas cette relation comme on a avec
l'argent qu'on leur colle pas des
contrôles fiscaux tous les ans aux
hommes politiques parce que nous on en a
des contrôles fiscaux mémoire le golf ne
m'a demandé des explications ouais quand
je suis devenu ministre je pense que on
a demandé l'estimation de mes maisons et
c'est ce qui est tout à fait légitime
les hommes politiques fassent des
déclarations
que ces déclarations soient contrôlés
très contrôlé même pas une commission
parlementaire pourquoi pas qu'en cas de
doute il y ait une enquête est très
profonde pourquoi pas mais pourquoi a
demandé aux gens d'étaler sur la place
publique c'est qu'ils ont est à la fois
l'homme politique est un homme comme les
autres et bénéficie lui aussi de
l'article 9 du code civil a indiqué
qu'elle appliquait la protection de la
vie privée et surtout il ya c'est
peut-être de nature à aa
a découragé des gens de rentrer en
politique des gens qui serait formidable
équipe et qui pour équilibrer c'est à
dire que finalement si c'est ce système
là non ils n'ont pas envie d'aller dans
pourquoi pas plutôt des fonctionnaires
qui font de la politique yves je crois
qu'on est aujourd'hui toute manière dans
une société du doute c'est à dire qu'on
doute de tout est alors il ya deux
catégories de doute il ya le doute
effectivement qui est attisée je dirais
par une espèce de jalousie ses vis-à-vis
du personnel politique en disant mais
finalement c'est tous des poux ils sont
riches s'en mettent plein les fouilles
ça et puis il ya le doute sur ce qu'ils
disent et c'est ce doute laquelle plus
grave c'est quand vous avez un président
de la république qui vous dis moi il ya
le chômage la courbe du chômage sera
versé d'ici à la fin de l'année il ment
il ment quand il dit ça parce qu'il sait
très bien que il pourra pas alors
regardez le doute on est parti la
semaine dernière avec une révélation
c'est lui qui nous le dit bah finalement
j'ai un compte de 600000 euros à
singapore aujourd'hui on est à combien
on est à 15 millions d'euros la semaine
prochaine on sera à 5 ans dans le sud
façon à 6 ans nos deux héros de tout les
temps je suis souffre pas de compte
évidemment mais c'est déjà les petits
ferait baisser le pourboire nous des
banques et donc il ya un réel problème
dans cette société je crois que si on
veut rétabli la parole publique et la
parole de ceux qui nous gouvernent
il faut déjà qu'il soit sincère et vrai
dans ce qu'ils disent sur le plan du jeu
mais regardez il ya un truc incroyable
eva joly oui et quand même une fille
honnête lv2 qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des héros il fait 10 % c'est que les
gens ont-ils envie d'avoir des hommes
politiques intègres parce que non aux
dernières élections et vous savez on
fonctionne par mode si l'année dernière
on était pas sur ce mode là c'est vrai
que bayrou il n'a rien fait là il a
absolument s'il a dit un petit peu il va
un référendum effet une pétition il
prend 10 points d'un coup histoire alors
qu'il a rien dit plus que ce qu'ils
disaient dernière edouard votre
patrimoine alors attendez c'est
important vous avez quoi vous alors moi
j'ai une maison qui appartient à la
banque
je n'ai toujours pas fini de payer et
j'ai une voiture qui a 10 ans 170 mille
kilomètres donc si je vais la vendre ce
qui naquit pas cher 2300 euros c'est un
campagnol mais on va vous aider c'est
max faure d'assez invendables
je veux dire par là c'est quand même
assez pathétique à à quoi on assiste il
ya une chanson de banderoles qui
disaient il suffit pas d'être pauvre
pour être honnête j'ai d'une que je
comprends votre démarche on est
vachement de la démago là c'est à dire
voilà moi je suis plus blanc que blanc
quand ça c'est coluche valise est simple
mais mais à côté de ça moi je pense si
on veut éviter ces dérives c'est qu'il
faut arrêter de faire de la politique un
métier tout ce qu'ils ont fait d'un
politique donc ce n'était pas le métier
la passion depuis le plus jeune âge ils
se sont plantés
pourquoi parce que en france quand vous
êtes à la tête d'un ministère vous êtes
à la tête d'une administration
si vous ne savez pas faire marcher cette
administration là et bien vous faites
buffet par cette administration
parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
politiques mais ceux qui appliquent la
politique est souvent qu'ils prennent
les devants par rapport à leur ministre
ce sont les hauts fonctionnaires qui
prennent kiki qui rendent prisonniers
quasiment leur ministre et quand vous
êtes amateurs vous êtes avocats
syndicalistes rugbyman pourquoi pas
enfin il y en a eu et bien mou retrouver
à la tête du nanisme en fait de la com
savait-il à côté
compass au conflit d'intérêts alors
quelle profession sont compatibles avec
les mandats électoraux par exemple
avocat d'affaires c'est sur ses
complices est une profession avocat
d'affaires vous pouvez avoir un cabinet
dans lequel vous avez certains de vos
collaborateurs qui font du pénal
d'autres qui font des divorces et un
troisième de troisième catégorie qui
font les contrats des fusées des fusions
acquisitions mais est-ce qu'à ce moment
là on peut être un homme politique
quand on fait des fusions acquisitions
et c est ce qu on peut être juge et
partie à mon avis est que certaines
activités qu'il faut peut-être pointé
recensés sans jeter l'opprobre dessus
d'ailleurs parce que faire des fusions
acquisitions quand on est ado mais ya
rien de mal à ça non il ya un conflit
d'intérêt par exemple dont on parle
jamais c'est pourquoi les gens et bien
que leur mère soit ministre parce que si
j'ai des trucs pour la région et voilà
comment s'est construit l'autoroute de
l'art de la science mais recommencer
c'est le comment s'est construit une
autoroute de bordeaux avec un bon delmas
facilite
bien alors maintenant les paradis
fiscaux alors il ya une arme qui est
très efficace c'est l'échangé
automatique de renseignements entre les
pays tiers que dès qu'un conte s'ouvre
dans le monde l'info est transmise aux
autorités du pays de celui qui vient de
l'ouvrir c'est ce que font les
américains ça c'est une arme extrêmement
efficace simplement pour adopter une
méthode pareil en europe il faut qu'ils
aient l'humilité
sauf qu'on en retient luxembourg est un
paradis fiscal et le triche qui en est
presque 1 donc qu'est ce qu'on fait là
c'est pas normal quand le rock c'est
vrai il y ait des paradis fiscaux dans
l'union européenne au moins 1000 et de
sa part est complètement aberrant sur
est en revanche vous c'était un cas ou
comment vous faites vous êtes que vous
êtes industriel vous monter une affaire
avec un chinois le chinois la règle
c'est que la société est inscrite dans
un paradis du sud est asiatique
c'est ce qui est arrivé est arrivé à
ogier
il est d'hollande mon copain d'hollande
voilà qui a monté une société avec un
chinois et qui a pris donc des parts
dans une société aux îles caïmans ce qui
fait maintenant dix plus gauche caviar
en gauche caïman
éradiquer tous les paradis fiscaux dans
le monde j'y crois pas de seconde mais
monsieur quand vous avez un compte à
l'étranger ben vous avez qu à le
déclarer tout simplement vous donner un
exemple mais cet exemple il est tout à
fait viable à condition que ce soit
ouvert et transparent a déclaré voilà
d'accord est ce que les banques doivent
publier la liste de leurs filiales à
l'étranger bah ça se fait déjà dire que
tout ce qui a été annoncé le mercredi
par le président de la république il ya
au moins les deux tiers de ce qu'il a
dit existe déjà sauf que pour certaines
de ces mesures on attend encore les
décrets d'application l'application
regardez vous avez vu tout à l'heure
nicolas sarkozy le rapport sauvé le
rapport sauvé alors ça devait rentrer en
application vous verrez ça ne se passera
plus jamais alors la hollande 12e chose
quand ce que le prochain président de la
république nous dira encore la même
chose mais tout ça va passer dans des
lois ça va être votée le 24 avril s'est
présenté devant le conseil devrait soit
voter ensuite ça sera voté l'application
les deux occasions n'ont jamais pris ça
sera présenté devant l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat avec un vrai débat
public voilà donc suivant les choses
dans la transparence là aussi moi il ya
un truc qui me fascine c'est qu'en fait
il ya usa qui se fait choper bon c'est
dommage pour lui mais on sait tout ça
nous amène hollande en profite pour
faire la moralisation de la politique
donc est ce que pour faire oublier
cahuzac il n'est pas en train de monter
une usine à gaz qui finalement les gens
ils s'en foutent un peu passé quand vous
interviewer des gens dans la rue ils
vous disent de toute façon ils sont tous
corrompus sont pas spécialement surpris
les jambes les gens s'en foutent moi
j'ai peur du coup aussi pour la jeunesse
je me dis qu'elle quel message ça envoie
à des gens de mon âge où des gens plus
jeunes ça nous donne aucune envie de
voter aucune omis nous investir dans la
vie politique
voilà à quoi ça sert de deux décès de
découvrir ce qu'est la droite ou de ces
de découvrir ce qu'est la gauche m'a
rien parce qu'on n'y comprend rien sans
vous êtes tous pareils donc les gens
s'en foutent pas mais ces gens ils
arriveront 10 par an
ils veulent des gens honnêtes volage
lechantre et de même parce que j étais
place de la bastille quand il a été élu
ce que tu te rends compte que françois
hollande je ne sais pour quelle raison
pour nous les jeunes on avait
l'impression de revivre ce que vous avez
vécu jeune à l'époque de mitterrand que
nous n'avons pas connu nous pour nous
c'était l'eldorado ça y est la droite le
petit avec sa montre et est parti alors
on avait de roupiller sa bonne tête qui
nous disaient vous allez voir je vais
vous emmener résultat il nous a menti
résultats il n'y a toujours pas assez
écoutée par la sienne si vous avez 10 et
les flancs oui quand des marges et un
bris et oui oui quand c'est flou c'est
qu'il ya un loup
non
on conclurait ce qu'il fallait pas venu
engagé 3000 inspecteurs du fisc et faire
une grande opération mains propres alors
les hommes les inspecteurs du fisc il
embauchera pas 3000 et on préfère les
mettre à l'éducation nationale à la lys
à la justice mais il va en embaucher
justement pour que pour renforcer le
parquet pour que le parquet et six
filles parties spéciales un parquet
spécial puisse mettre mener des enquêtes
réel par rapport à ceux qui placent de
l'argent et qui a dû trancher merci à
tous yves merci d'avoir été à jean marie
arlette merci d'avoir été avec nous car
deux hommes vont rencontrer vous
souhaiter la paix de dieu et c'est le
pied on se retrouve après la pub avec
les années 15 partout et notre avis
20h01 ce choix aurélien brûlé
[Musique]
5 gimont de bornéo et c'est un malheur
sur les ça va nous changer lequel
jacques il s'agit bon
[Musique]
bonsoir l'intérieur jean ravon soir les
terriens nous sommes toujours en
compagnie des n'aura malagré
et patrick bruel
et des doigts matin
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir aurélien brûlé
bonsoir
alors aurélien enfin tout le monde je
vous appelle chami ce qui veut dire
gibbons en taille en effet passionné par
le monde des singes depuis votre plus
jeune âge vous avez décidé à l'âge de 18
ans de vous installer en indonésie pour
sauver une espèce menacée par la chasse
et la déforestation
les gibbons
depuis vous vivez votre vie comme un
film d'aventuré vous nous raconter votre
histoire à 20h et maintenant j'accueille
gaspard proust pour elle est pas belle
la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi de neuf
rien
plus que mille quatre cent quatre-vingt
dix jours avant le retour de sarko à
l'elysée
elysée alors hollande est revenu faire
son au stand-up voileux l'elysée comedy
club au micro un pupitre plafond à
moulures et bout de vannes lorient a
encore fait une un stand up sur
l'autorité mois président vous
connaissez pas raul le truc là lui qui
fait un sketch sur l'autorité autant de
crédibilité que voir boutin interpréter
le lâcher de [ __ ]
alors ya une semaine il parlait d'un
choc de simplification et là il décide
de créer une haute autorité de
surveillance
hollande créateurs de haute autorité
depuis 2012 c'est le truc c'est que des
c'est quoi ce terme de haute autorité ce
que je vais dire quand tu penses qu'il
existe une autorité c'est que tu crois
qu'il existe aussi une balle son
autorité c'est surtout donc que t'y
connais rien aux autorités
alors vous savez ce que c'est c'est un
mec qui bloquent l'entrée du ministère
de la défense avec un vélib ouais c'est
hollande qui fait une tentative de
putsch
[Applaudissements]
il paraît que les grands leaders se
révèle dans la crise quand on voit le
mal qui se donne pour gérer une histoire
de reebok
alors inutile de dire qu'il n'a pas
mentionné héros pauvre jean marc ayrault
qui a apporté son soutien à borloo qui a
demandé une commission denquête sur
l'action du gouvernement durant la
sphère cahuzac du jamais vu c'est le
premier ministre qui est d'accord de
faire une commission pour être au
courant de ce qui se passe sous sa
responsabilité
alors opération transparence tout le
monde à poil mois le franchement
j'aurais préféré rien savoir vraiment je
voudrais fillon qui a une bicoque dans
la sarthe duflot une twingo à 1500 euros
belkacem un livret à philippe hitié à
l'appartement de 70 m² on demande au
ministre de l'eau n'était pas de faire
pitié
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est ça c'est cette idée grandiose
indus plus tu es pauvre plus c'est bien
vu qu'on sait c'est un truc la france
avec le seul pays au monde dont les fier
de gagner le smic de rouler encore un
goût et de bouffer au fun
mais si on continue comme ça même les
roms voudront plus venir
il ce truc de transparence certains ça
va aller [ __ ] marc savard et déjà des
rumeurs sur fabius quand paraît qu'il
est en train de vendre ses tableaux pour
acheter un stock de kangoo
c'est l'image passer l'image en tout cas
avec toutes ces histoires patrimoine on
sait au moins une chose moscovici ne
savait rien sur cahuzac devrait il a
aucun flair ce type j'ai regardé son
patrimoine le tipi la duplex impôts
belliard
la seule façon de faire une plus-value
la basse et s'il ya une montée du niveau
de la mer de 15 m
amour eva joly appelle à manifester avec
mélenchon le 5 mai prochain il fallait
bien qu'ils se rencontrent les deux quoi
cela pouvait que connectés quoi c'est la
comédie romantique trotskiste de l'année
où quand robespierre rencontre elena
ceausescu c'est après hiroshima mon
amour le goulag dure trois ans les
dipôles potes
ou l'histoire d'une scandinaves qui à la
ménopause découvre en même temps
l'orgasme et la langue française
[Musique]
parlant de cinéma cinéma engagé
véronique genest déclare dans le figaro
pourquoi j'arrête julie lescaut ah mais
oui pourquoi pour une fois qu'on avait
une série policière qui rivalisait avec
les meilleures productions ouzbek
tourisme alors je sais pas si tout le
monde a vu cette photo de kim jong hun
mahjong de au backgammon 3h et plus va
bien
mais qu'il est fort faire croire au
monde entier qui va lancer une attaque
nucléaire alors qu'il fait du cheval en
camargue
c'est franchement c'est pas avec cette
photo qui fera trembler le monde a faim
on dirait attila avec des problèmes de
cholestérol c'est pas
moi et moi je fais de la peine mois
conclut panda s'est paumé parmi ces
généraux là on dirait un petit obèses
kidnappé par une maison de retraite du
xiiie arrondissement
métaphysique des liquides il paraît que
cahuzac était franc maçon ah ah oui
alors le nom de sa loge c'est locarno 28
à kohat une ville suisse il est fort
pour brouiller les pistes lui quand
c'est un truc alors les gens évidemment
on se dira mais c'est quoi un
franc-maçon alors un franc-maçon comment
dire c'est trop snob pour être cateau
pas assez célèbre pour être juif
non je réfléchis
montorier de la matière nécrologie
margaret thatcher est morte
thatcher on peut dire ce qu'on veut dire
là peut-être pas fait beaucoup pour les
mineures mais sans elle on n'aurait sans
doute jamais connu les clashs et les sex
pistols
alors jean luc mélenchon estime que
margaret thatcher va découvrir en enfer
ce qu'elle a fait aux mineurs vu le
poids politique du front de gauche c'est
surtout jean luc mélenchon qui
découvrira en enfer ce qui l'a pas fait
pour les mineurs
[Applaudissements]
moi je me méfie quoi un athée qui
croient à l'enfer mais ça c'est le
problème des laïques enragent et pressés
sont tellement sûrs que dieu n'existe
pas qui s'estime légitime pour prendre
sa place face et un truc les journaux
évidemment se demande si il faudrait une
margaret thatcher en france ce serait
chouette un
nom mais elle à florange au lieu de vous
proposer un reclassement elle se serait
arrangé pour vous filer la nationalité
indienne
[Rires]
ansari au quartier
aura pas ton à greg jeu de mots alors le
grand rabbin de france gilles bernheim
déjà coupable de plagiat en plus usurpé
son à greg de philo ta manque plus qu on
découvre qu'ils organisaient des soirées
jean brouillette avec tariq ramadan
[Applaudissements]
la rousse définition du mot mariage a
été modifié c'est plus l'union de deux
personnes de sexes opposés mais l'union
de deux personnes de sexe opposé ou de
même sexe bab la littérature c'est faux
faux tout réécrire marriage act
précédent le divorce et dont le but est
de faire une jolie fête lorsque tout le
monde se supportent encore
c'est cepal seul terme a et réécrire un
relais à d'autres comme filiation act
qui permet de retrouver le connard ou la
[ __ ] à qui on n'a rien demandé
adoption coup de pouce du destin qui
permet à certains gosses de tomber sur
des parents plus compétents que ce livre
est d'origine
après une nuance enfants adoptés
vietnamiens enfants très prisé par la
bourgeoisie du 16e arrondissement du
fait de la ressemblance physique qu'il
développe avec la mère adoptive une fois
qu'elle a passé ses premiers lifting
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer c'est pierre bergé vos des
préservatifs gratuits au collège comme
si les profs n'avait pas les moyens de
s'en acheter
alors
celui-là sur canalplus.fr et demain à 15
ans 5 sur canal+ on passe maintenant à
notre invité du samedi 20 heures
chagny rebond soir vous êtes né le 2
juillet 1979 à fréjus sous le nom de
aurélien brûlé j'espère agents
immobiliers maire secrétaire comptable
chez un notaire alors vous grandissez à
fayence c'est un très joli village du
var dans la garrigue et dès votre plus
jeune âge vous êtes fasciné par le monde
des singes à partir de 10 ans il
collectionne tous les bouquins les
images tout ce qui concerne le monde des
singes ouais y'a un moment vous décidez
de prendre contact avec un primatologue
donc jean yves caullet saison n'avait
que 11 ans à ce moment là et là votre
mère vous emmène le voir dans les alpes
c'est ça et il vous dit bah écoutez
commencer par aller au zoo bah oui j'ai
11 12 ans que faire d'autre mais avoir
des singes alors aux autres fréjus donc
à une espèce qui attire votre attention
ce sont les gibbons il m'attire part
c'est un coup de foudre mais simplement
avec mes yeux d'enfant ils me paraissent
pas bien ils me paraissent triste et
sont toujours tout seul et je me dis
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour les
aider vous y allez tous les mercredis
après midi mais sont payés quand même
sans payer mais voilà alors que les
copains partait au foot joué et c'est à
moi j'allais avec les singes et ça
pendant de quelques années évidemment
c'est difficile pour vous parce que
quand on passe son temps avec les
gibbons on a du mal à se faire des potes
quoi ces sages était toujours le gard un
petit peu étrange ça soit au collège
antipolis et voilà je passe mon temps
avec les singes donc avec les filles
tout ça ça marche et ça marche et moi on
accroche mais c'était à c'était vraiment
pas ce temps et je me sentais utile
auprès d'eux alors vos observations aux
autres fréjus vont durer cinq ans et
vous finissez par comprendre pourquoi il
ya de la détresse dans les yeux des
gibbons les gibbons sont monogames et
pour se reproduire ils ont besoin
d'aimer leurs compagnes voilà en fait
c'est les directeurs de zoos qui décide
avec qui les maîtres donc ils sont
enfermés dans des cages à des gonzesses
qu'ils aiment pas en gros c'est ça il
faut apprendre à former des couples
encore jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui on
sait pas trop comment ils se choisissent
alors au collège ça va pas fort dont
vous n'êtes pas très heureux
en mode de vie scolaire et la 1 mercredi
il fait froid les gibbons sont dans leur
cabane jette appuyé contre la cage et
soudain il ya une petite main qui prend
délicatement la vôtre c'est une femelle
gibbons qui est sorti de sa cabane elle
grelotte elle vous regarde et elle vous
réconforte en voilà et pour moi c'est un
déclic parce que à ce moment là quand je
me retourne donc ça va pas bien et quand
je croise son regard je me dis tiens
elle a été là pour moi à ce moment là et
j'avais besoin de quelqu'un à ce moment
là c'était un gibbons il se trouve que
c'était un gibbons mais à ce moment là
je lui ai fait une promesse que j'étais
encore au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est tout
faire pour elle et pour ses congénères
c'est ça vous décidé de consacrer
d'autres vies ou gibbons à ce moment là
c'est pas rien grâce surtout à l'âge que
vous aviez alors à 16 ans vous décidez
de faire un livre sur les gibbons et à
la sortie du lit vous donner une
interview à vsd et la gérante du lycée
de téléphone sonne je décroche un mur
elle robin alors je la crois pas
évidemment dans un premier temps les
faits si c'est bien moi j'ai lu un
article sur toi tu veux partir sauver
les singes les gibbons en asie et bien
tu pars je vais t'aider et je serai
toujours là
muriel robin
alors en 1981 du siècle une semaine
après votre bac ou 3d l'avion direction
thaïlande dc live devenait chagny c'est
ça veut dire en fait j bon en taille
impossible de prononcer aurélien pour
les thaïlandais un rôle phare c'est mon
temps à chercher ces singes ils m'ont
appelé tout simplement le giron chef les
chaînes trois mois plus tard vous
reprenez l'avion sans trop savoir quoi
faire pour le gibbon et dans l'avion en
lisant un journal vous découvrez la
catastrophe écologique qu'est la
déforestation de l'indonésie pour
planter des palmiers pour faire de
l'huile de palme est en fait on part on
tue l'habitat des singes et d'autres
animaux donnaient pas qu'on perdait 2
millions d'hectares de forêts sur bornéo
et sumatra donc plus de forêts donc plus
les gibbons et tous les autres animaux
évidemment donc je me dis si je veux
aider les gibbons c'est pas la thaïlande
c'est l'indonésie parce que c'est là bas
qu'il se passe le plus de choses il n'y
a plus de problème en mai 1998 un an
plus tard vous avez déjà carta et vous
découvrez la manière dont les gibbons
sont capturées un lot de captures
pourquoi alors ils sont vendus comme
jouets vivants donc pas animal de
compagnie peluches jouets vivants il
s'est mis dans une cage et on sent
divers types ensuite on l'oubli donc tu
la mère de l'un forêt pour récupérer le
bébé la mère fait une chute de 60 mètres
comme les gibbons sont monogames toute
la cellule familiale en fait disparaît
dans la forêt pour un seul bébé vendus
sur le marché vous découvrirez comme
indonésie en fait c'est chic d'avoir un
gibbons dans une cage devant chez soi en
forme de prestige d'avoir des sauvages
dont des gibbons sont donc c'est surtout
les personnes riches les hauts
fonctionnaires qui vont avoir comme ça
des singes devant chez eux et voilà mais
il faut savoir qu'en captivité dans ces
conditions les animaux vont vivre au
maximum 5 7 ans alors que dans la nature
ils vont vivre plus de 30 ans à la hâte
une espèce de diane fossey quoi en fait
oui évidemment c'est un combat or le
problème c'est que le gouvernement
indonésien et peu motivés par la
préservation des gibbons alors pour vous
c'est dur évidemment parce que vous avez
plus d'argent c'est pas trop comment
faire et là vous est recueilli par une
famille dans un bidonville rencontre un
des fils de la famille dans la rue il
vient voir un thé chez moi je suis resté
neuf mois celui-ci est
donc j'ai appris l'indonésien pendant ce
temps là ça me permettait d'aller tous
les jours au ministère des forêts 1 à
jakarta pour faire la une pression sur
les autorités pour qu'ils me signer un
papier pour m'autoriser à créer le
premier programme de conservation de
cette espèce donc s'il faut dire que
c'était en mai 98 donc du coup c'est la
chute du président ce soir tôt à
l'époque en indonésie on a des blindés
dans tous les coins de rue à jakarta les
voilà et mais j'ai continué et muriel à
l'époque était importante les envoyés
des messages envoyés des facs vas-y fond
je suis sûr qu'il va y arriver doute pas
fonce alors j'avais un j'avais pas le
roi de la décevoir vous n'êtes pas
d'argent et là bas pour se faire un peu
de thunes les mots me font la
circulation
on vous retrouve est en train de faire
la circulation à des cartes dans les
rues jakarta
comme j'étais blanc justement ça rassure
prenais beaucoup les automobilistes et
du coup il donner la pièce beaucoup plus
facilement donc divin c'était de la
bonne affaire se vanta les gamins qui
était alors finalement dans vous signé
un accord avec le gouvernement
indonésien et vous partez à bornéo pour
protéger les gibbons et vous comprenez
très vite en fait en arrivant que vous
ne ferai rien sans le soutien de la
population locale et qu'il faut devenir
indonésien donc vous prenez la
nationalité indonésienne puis alors il
ya un truc c'est que en indonésie la
religion est marqué sur le passeport
alors on est obligé quand on voit
marquer catholique c'est gênant dans
vous convertissez à 10 la voile a choisi
l'islam parce que c'est le plus grand
pays musulman au monde sauf que sauf que
circoncision voilà aurélien et oui il
faut y passer donc tueur préparation
psychologique et ak47 c'est sûr
conscient là à 22 ans mal à ça fait mal
chez dc à sept jours et puis et puis je
déconseille le matin d'avoir des
émotions fortes après la circoncision
aïe aïe aïe alors pour faire connaître
votre action a eu une idée géniale vous
créez une radio alors c'est une radio
qui donne des infos sur les gibbons
espagne radio j en rêve parce que lui ce
qui est bien c'est qu'avec lui
l'écologie c'est fun le but c'est quoi
c'est de faire en sorte que le gamin qui
a priori s'en fiche des gibbons s'en
fichent de la forêt reçoit le message
que je vais lui donner ce qu'il a envie
de la musique des canulars antenne une
émission des démissions rigolote et
cetera mais quelles que soient les
missions quelle que soit l'heure de
diffusion on va avoir ses petites
pastilles et ça fait maintenant
longtemps que ça dure et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à avoir on à 10000 à 15000
auditeurs sur 24 heures derrière nous et
on arrive à faire la différence si je
compare à la france sur une chaîne comme
où on a des documentaires si la personne
a déjà fait la démarche d'aller voir ce
documentaire sur cette chaîne - déjà
sensibilisés par contre sur une émission
de divertissement où les gens
s'attendent pas du tout à avoir de
l'environnement c'est là où on va
toucher le gamin qui a priori on n'en a
rien à faire donc c'est exactement ce
principe là c'est très intelligent alors
vous devenez vraiment un spécialiste des
animaux une espèce dit diana jones tient
comme ça une panthère qui rentre dans un
à visage on vous appelle c'est ça c'est
que je serai pour les gibbons mais il ya
énormément d'autres animaux qui sont en
détresse et qui font si des soucis aux
populations quand l'habitat disparaît
mais justement des panthères des ours
rentrer dans les villages donc on nous
appelle pour éliminer soucis mais faire
en sorte que l'animal soit sauvé aussi
relâché trop maîtriser une panthère
aurait alors c'est arrivé une panthère
qui attaque une jeune enfant dans un
village on l'a piégé pour attraper la
patte antérieure ensuite par derrière en
tirer la queue pour l'écarteler en fait
avec le poids du corps dessus avec une
injection pour le pôle endormir de
kétamine de kétamine c'est un
anesthésiant vous avez fait la même
chose et comme l'ours avec tous deux été
blessés avec louis la main gauche un
mordu par un ours mais oui c'est plein
de risques mais c'est beaucoup de
systèmes d'e on et à bornéo avait on
essaie de faire la différence avec peu
de choses évidemment
problème d'abord les compagnies qui
deforest pour faire de l'huile de palme
évidemment c'est pas vos copains les
braconniers
certaines fois la police alors vous avez
été génial un jour ya la police qui
arrive là où ils sont et ils enferment
l'animateur de l'émission dans le studio
et l'animateur de l'émission raconte
l'arrivée de la police en direct ce qui
fait que la police finit par se tirer
parce que les auditeurs commencent à
arriver et eux qui étaient arrivés pour
nous intimider en bombant le torse quand
ils ont vu arriver 5 10 15 20 auditeurs
alors aujourd'hui à kalaweit donc il ya
243 gibbons en soi un crocodile des ours
des panthères des pythons il faut 5
tonnes de fruits par semaine c'est ça
pour nous l'argent comment on revient
principalement par des dons en france et
des grandes fondations comme la
fondation brigitte bardot la fondation
30 millions d'amis notre premier sponsor
sien c'est aussi un parc zoologique en
france par exemple de ville puis ensuite
c'est les donateurs les gens peuvent
donner sur le séjour le chef qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran magique on a
besoin au minimum d'un budget de 450
mille euros par an 1 et devant nous on
n'a jamais plus de deux ou à trois mois
au niveau financier se tenir donc tu es
toujours en fuite en dut en fait vous
avez fini par épouser une indonésienne
est marié depuis 11 ans avec prada c'est
ça 15 en indonésie 11 ans marié avec
prada j'ai deux enfants maintenant moi
lorenzo est ce que vous dites finalement
c'est que l'écologie ça peut être fun
c'est ça doit être comparé à ce que
lorsque nous on fait tout pour provoquer
l'orgasme de notre partenaire et c'est
exactement ça c'est faire du bien faut
pas se poser de questions j'ai
l'impression qu'en france quand on parle
d'écologie faut absolument être déprimés
pour être bonne un bon écolo alors que
c'est pas ça mais voilà
alors je rappelle le titre de votre
livre ça s'appelle le sourire fendu et
ceux publiés aux éditions du strapontin
vraiment acheté le voilà c'était salut
les terriens
votre tour du samedi avec marie arlette
carlotti ministre délégué aux handicapés
et à la lutte contre l'exclusion pour
marcel mcapital recherche midi enora
malagré touche pas à mon poste du lundi
au vendredi à 18h15 sur des vies patrick
bruel
l'album lequel de nous étudions dans les
bacs il était en tournée dans toute la
france
edouard martin pour ne lâchons rien aux
éditions du cherche midi yves thréard du
figaro aurélien brûlé à chagny merci
votre témoignage je vous laisse avec
roland salut les terriens
m
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu